make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
on the wings of love up in above the
clouds the only way to fly is on the
wings of love hello everyone this is Rob
how are you guys doing you guys doing
good you guys doing okay
I'm glad in this video we are covering
Franklin Richards becoming the Phoenix
yes we are Franklin Richards gets the
Phoenix force now this takes place in
the ultimate universe those two guys you
don't know about the ultimate universe
of Marvel comic the ultimate universe is
basically what the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is based off of I we talked
about that multiple times at the MCU is
based off a combination of the ultimate
universe the main Marvel Universe and
Earth 98 or heroes aged in real time and
so with that in mind the Ultimate
Universe imprint was launched in 2000
with the idea of basically answering the
question what would the Marvel Universe
look like if it was essentially the
world outside your window if it was more
real and more tangible
now the Phoenix force as it exists in
the alternate universe is a little bit
different from the Phoenix and the
Marvel Universe but also still the same
and the reason why is because as we know
what the Phoenix is this omniversal
force but the Phoenix itself is a
singular entity like The Living Tribunal
but there exists one facsimile of the
Phoenix force of one piece of itself in
every single universe that exists out
there right it's just how that person
uses that power right so technically
speaking if a person in one universe
became the white Phoenix of the crown
the way that Jean Grey did in the main
Marvel Universe they would tap into the
full totality of its power but the
indication that Marvel's given us over
the years is you can only ever have one
white Phoenix of a crown at a time
because that's a person that basically
possesses the full totality of the
Phoenix forces power right and so you
can't really possess the full totality
of its power if everybody has that power
and it's kind of crazy the way this
unfolds because like as this pops off
you immediately have will reign who's
just like this is a hijacking anybody
here who don't want to take a dirt nap
get off this train right like everybody
relax nobody move and then in turn we
find out that he's with what looks like
Captain America right and it's kind of
nuts because it's like okay so like wise
kind of Captain America hijacking a
train it's really kind of a crazy
scenario and so what we end up getting
here is also Kitty Pryde who has the
web-shooters of spider-man now flows you
guys asking how it is that this happens
in the Ultimate Universe by Kitty Pryde
the one-time girlfriend of spider-man
button so the indication here is that
she you know of course ended up getting
spider-man's web shooters and so from
there we end up having Franklin
basically imbuing the powers or or
seemingly emanating the powers of the
Phoenix now he doesn't use them right
off the bat he simply just kind of
glowing orange and that's when people
basically start asking like are you sure
this is gonna work and the responsible
rain is yes you know definitely the fact
that like Rogan Wolverine is together is
a little weird a little strange
something I'm definitely not used to
seeing rogue and magneto were thing back
in the 1990s during Age of Apocalypse
which is really a story I wish they'd
continued but what this does is this
train basically kind of goes crashing
into a building and when that happens we
basically end up switching over to the
Baxter building in the modern day with
regards to the Fantastic Four now the
Fantastic Four during the Ultimate
Universe and it was actually one of the
most interesting iterations of their
character are starkly different in a lot
of ways from the Fantastic Four in main
Marvel Universe right the Fantastic Four
the main Marvel Universe that's the
Fantastic Four you know right like nerdy
Reed Richards and like he's a guy who
could just never really get the girl but
somehow managed to land Susan storm and
then dr. doom is the villain all that
kind of stuff in the Ultimate Universe
Reed Richards was a dick like it was
crazy he ended up becoming like a
villain he became the maker he literally
created this entire Citadel where he
just sorted creating human beings and
then aging them over the course of like
a thousand generations or something
along those lines but these were always
on the fence between Reed and Susan
right in the main mobile universe be
they do have like their squabbles in the
sense that like they bicker with each
other and including the events of Civil
War it looked like they were gonna get a
divorce right but it never really got
that close instead there was always them
just basically reconciling and things
getting back to normal and really one of
the big issues that came between the two
of them was Reed focusing on his work
right during Jonathan Hickman's
legendary run of the Fantastic Four the
idea of Reed trying to solve the problem
of everything what you end up having
here was Reed who was just really really
cocky and arrogant he was just a total
jerk and ended up becoming a villain the
problem with this is that in the middle
of this whole thing where he's talking
to Susan this train comes crashing in
right like this train from from the
future comes crashing into this building
and it's kind of nuts because these
x-men of course you have like Johnny you
have Ben Grimm who show up the thing who
show up and and you've got like the
x-men who show up here assuming they all
alongside Captain America and it's kind
of like okay you know what the world is
going on and they greet Reed Richards
and it's kind of like okay you know like
we're essentially from the future right
and we're looking for the Fantastic Four
we're trying to get a hold of Reed and
it's like well you know I mean what can
I help you with and the response is
you can die and they immediately attack
him right late like Wolverine and
basically stabs him with his claws and
things kind of pop off now one of the
cool things about Wolverine that I want
to talk about here while we're well
related to this battle one of the things
that goes on with Wolverine is that in
the Ultimate Universe he's not the same
as the main Marvel Universe right we've
seen that like Wolverines adamantium is
basically indestructible in the main
Marvel Universe in the Ultimate Universe
it's just a really really really strong
metal but it can still be broken the
other half of this is that reads body
cannot be easily destroyed and there's
argument to make there that he is in a
lot of ways essentially amoral right the
ways to kill him you can count on one
hand it's exceedingly difficult to do
moreso than that we also end up finding
out that with these x-men being from the
future the experiences they've had the
training they've experienced is pretty
significant and so far that Kitty Pryde
simply had the ability to alter the
molecular structure of her body so she
could face through solid matter
this future counterpart to her has
essentially learned she can make her
body super light so she can even go so
far as to fly but has also made it
exceedingly dense to make herself
super-strong we're just not nobility
that we've really seen her demonstrate
before it is a cool adjustment to her
character the other part of this is that
you have Susan storm who uses her
ability to encase Franklin Richards now
there's precedent for this and a lot of
people would look at this and say
Franklin using the power of the Phoenix
should be able to overcome this but we
saw during Donovan Hickman's Fantastic
Four run that Susan storms force field
can actually hold off the power of
Celestials so there's there's precedents
here for the power of students storms
shields the other half of this is again
we can kind of go with this idea that
Franklin hasn't quite learned how to use
the full totality of the Phoenix powers
right either that who recently not the
white Phoenix of the crown now in this
universe the Phoenix is the origin point
of all life in this universe where the
creation of sentient life came from the
Phoenix we know it's at least
universally powerful you know now we
know the Phoenix as a whole is a
multiversal force so as a greater entity
it's nonstop right it represents the sum
total of all life that has ever
currently does and will ever exist but
again within this universe
it looks like Franklin hasn't learned to
use the full totality of its abilities
at least not in this regard and so what
it does is it basically leads to what
looks like the power of the Phoenix of
the power of Franklin basically grabbing
Reed and then leaving and so of course
Susan storm and everybody else is this
group is flying away Susan storm and
everybody else end up jumping in and
saying okay we have to go get the x-men
from
modern day and this is a cool thing
because when they show up here of course
you've essentially got Jean who's more
or less leading the show or leading the
charge but you've also got things like
Susan storm using her psychic abilities
for lack of a better word the ability to
create force fields things like that
it's being far more nuanced than it used
to be right like being able to create
what equates to Wolverines claws it's a
cool it's a cool Display of power here
that's kind of what's going on Wolverine
is whole heartedly against this right
the present day will reign is wholly
against like invading the Baxter
building you know different things like
that you know and it's kind of like read
probably had it coming right especially
because read it turned on the on the
x-men somewhere along the line at least
that seems to be the indication here and
so the responses okay then like let's
basically kind of start working together
right he knows Jean Grae entering the
mind of Wolverines saying you need to
calm down
like we need your help on this right
Wolverine is still a pretty informal
enemy right his healing factor is not as
efficient as it is in the main Marvel
Universe's big differences here but in a
lot of ways he's still kind of the ace
in the hole of the x-men team and so
with that in case Jean in the modern day
as the Phoenix basically says I can use
this power to essentially locate you
know wherever these x-men are and when
she starts picking up and starts homing
in what she realizes is that you know
the x-men when when it was believed they
left the Baxter building that never
actually happened that instead it was
franklin richards using his power to
trick the Fantastic Four what was left
of the Fantastic Four in a believing
that they left the other part of this
and this is one of the cool revelations
that comes out of this is that read you
know as you basically have the x-men
that that starts to leave the future
x-men who kind of go seemingly to a
different location Franklin Richards
starts to follow them and then Reed
stops him and he says have you told
anybody right like do they know and the
question is like what are we talking
about here and the reality is no one
knows that Franklin Richards is the son
of Reed right none of them know that and
it's kind of a crazy thing because while
we can't truly be killed this really
introduces the idea that he can
basically cause an immense amount of
pain and just kind of continues to
torture it right and it's one of these
these interesting things because the
truth is that Franklin doesn't really
even seem to know that he's the son of
Reed right like Franklin doesn't really
seem to know who his parents are at all
and before he really gets a chance to
read the mind of Reed to find out if
there's any truth to this he's impaled
from behind and when the the rest of the
x-men these future x-men come running in
it's like who in the heck it wasn't that
that attacked Franklin Richards
we end up having these sentinels that
have somehow made their way from the
future to the present day only for us to
find out these signals are Wolverine and
this is amazing right this is a really
really
idea and again this hits at the concept
that Wolverine is really kind of the one
of these unstoppable forces and we've
seen this take place in a myriad of
different comics over the years we've
seen it take place and what if comics
were Wolverine lived over a thousand
years and became this kind of Messiah
that led mutants into like a greater
future that was based on the Greg Rucka
story enemy in the state werewolves
reign was essentially brainwashed by the
hand and Hydra into going on kind of an
a crusade the what-if story focused on
that but wool rain was never stopped
right like nobody ever reversed it and
Wolverine ended up essentially killing
the Marvel Universe right like all in
almost all the superheroes on earth do a
combination of his training his his
bloodlust his berserker rage if he goes
into it and his healing factor as well
as that ax man tiem that Wolverine is a
one-man army and that if he sets out to
take out a target there's almost nothing
that can stop him right the best display
of that was during daniel ways uh
Wolverine Origins where he literally
broke into the White House right so like
it was it was cool to see these kinds of
things go on early it was cool to see
these scenarios take place but all these
berries they own guys started you know
these these Wolverines start coming
after these characters right they go
after Kitty Pryde of course she phases
and that takes care of things pretty
quickly at least in terms of her not
really having to worry about the various
Wolverines killing her but with the the
modern-day x-men team showing up on the
side they basically come across this
corpse like what in the world is going
on here right like like what's taking
place and that's what we end up
basically having like all these fleas
forces all these people have been chased
after in the the Wolverines in the
future have showed up and then you end
up learning to this Captain America is
not actually Captain America right like
that's not the case this Captain America
is actually Cyclops
right like that's what's going on what
we end up finding out here is that
somewhere along the line that the
Fantastic Four essentially turned on the
mutant population and when they did you
know Captain America was one of the
people to essentially fall right like
neo his his essentially like a kind of a
concept was introduced that basically
saw his serum in his body being removed
or being reduced but whatever it is he
aged a hundred years like that and so
Captain America ended up dying and it
responds to that basically Cyclops ended
up taking up the mantle in his stead and
that's really what's been going on here
right like the other cool thing about
this is we end up learning these
Wolverines aren't really doing it
intentionally the truth is that they
were basically taken they were co-opted
Wolverine himself was used to become the
template for all these sentinels when
either the Fantastic Four or whoever
they're working with ended up figuring
out how capable he was and discovering
that he's like
the perfect killing machine right he's
the perfect person to become a sentinel
right - to modify and turn into a bad
guy and so from there we end up jumping
into the future right like 20 years into
the future which is where all this
really seemed to pop off and you've got
Bobby Drake who's being chased after by
these Wolverine sentinels this is kind
of a cool thing here right because this
is very reminiscent and is really in a
lot of ways designed to mirror Days of
Future past right the worst-case
scenario for the x-men but those guys
aren't really familiar with that if you
enjoy future dystopian stories Days of
Future past was really kind of the first
big one right like that was polluted the
first big scenario that we got in the
x-men mythos where it was like this is
the future that awaits the x-men if
humanity ever decides to turn on them
activate the signal program and then we
see what happens when the signals become
self-aware and slave both humans and
mutants right but then we started
getting other futures like that
the Age of Apocalypse is a really good
example right that's hi mine was caused
by the son of Professor Xavier I got by
the name of Legion you might also know
him as is David Haller right but we've
also seen that take place in the story
bishop where we ended up warning that
Hope Summers who was the first mutant
that was born after the events of what
was called M day or the house of M where
the Scarlet Witch took away 98% of the
mutant populations powers she basically
ended up initiating this six second war
right where she wiped out a million
humans in six seconds and that basically
led to the same timeline as Bishop that
we've seen this play out in different
iterations what we end up having here is
a rule ended up finding out that Reed
has actually been taken by the Sentinels
right and that Reed has been taken to
the future and has kind of been locked
away
now of course Reed ends up using his
intelligence to effectively break out
because this prison wasn't really
designed to house somebody as smart as
Reed it was designed to house people
that were less intelligent than we right
so what better person to be able to
break out of his own prison than Reed
himself not only that he's actually
housed within the Baxter building right
so it's kind of wild because we end up
having these interesting introductions
here the idea that like namor the
sub-mariner has joined the Fantastic
Four that Ben Grimm seems to have was
essentially an Iron Man suit
we've got Liz Allen and I'm not gonna go
into who she is we'll talk more about
her at a future point but unless like we
basically have these characters here
right and so being in this future is
kind of wild because everything has
popped off for the mutant population
like they've been subjugated they're
being taken prisoner and the Fantastic
Four are the ones who led this crusade
against the entirety of the mutant
population but that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments explain
make sure you guys with the sub button
to become part of the rob port
- enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and we will wrap up the conclusion
in the next video Persis
[Music]
[Music]